plenty of questions are left to be
answered in episode 9 and Star Wars fans
can only hold out hope that it will
deliver from Ray's true heritage to
Lando Calrissian return these are just
some of the biggest questions fans have
going into the rise of Skywalker one of
the biggest mysteries within this new
trilogy has centered on Rey an extremely
talented Jedi in training who one might
assume comes from talented stock much
like Luke Skywalker who ended up serving
as her mentor in the last Jedi Rey
clearly comes from a storied family and
in the force awakens it seemed like the
next one or two installments might clear
up who her parents truly were and
whether or not she was a Skywalker a
solo or a member of another powerful
legacy plan and the last Jedi kylo Ren
broke the news to Rey that she was
nothing but the child of quote junk
traitors but naturally most fans don't
believe that a Jedi was such natural
talent who seems poised to take up the
lightsaber of someone like Luke
Skywalker came from a clan of nobodies
will the rise of Skywalker revealed that
she's actually a Skywalker all we can do
is wait and find out introduced in the
force awakens Maz Kanata has left
audiences curious since her first moment
on screen a wise being who's apparently
over a thousand years old
Maz is as inscrutable as she is
sarcastic and endlessly endearing when
we meet Maz she's managing a bar on the
planets of takodana
where she seems to know every person and
everything about them she also just
happens to be in possession of a pretty
damn important object Luke Skywalker's
lightsaber which she says calls to Rey
that lightsaber was Luke's and his
father's before him and now he calls to
you Maz Kanata is capable of using the
force so there are plenty of reasons why
she might have Luke's lightsaber one of
the most important items in the entire
Star Wars saga but it's still
unexplained when if or how exactly Maz
met Luke who is Maz and where did she
come from how did she know Luke how did
she get his lightsaber and how did she
use the Force to ascertain that it
should go to Rey
and in Episode nine teaser released in
April of 2019 audience's clearly heard
the distinctive chuckle of Emperor
Palpatine one of the signature villains
of the original trilogy and the prequel
as a Sith master of the infamous Darth
Vader the emperor is an imposing figure
throughout the series bringing the sit
back from the brink of extinction while
serving as the Emperor of the entire
Galactic Empire the Emperor is also
known for exterminating various Jedi
that he sees as potential threats
he's also also known for well being dead
that's never not satisfying anywho even
though Darth Vader ultimately redeems
himself by killing the Emperor in The
Return of the Jedi Palpatine's evil
laugh is clearly featured at the end of
the first rise of Skywalker teaser
surprisingly director JJ Abrams has
already confirmed that the Emperor will
appear in the film still played by actor
Ian McDermott I I have to be honest with
you I was in the area so I thought the
least I could do is to pop in for a love
McDermott has said the character is
definitely dead heading into the rise of
Skywalker but what role will he play in
the final installment of the series and
what form will he be taking when he does
return fans of the original trilogy fell
in love with Billy Dee Williams his
portrayal of the roguish if wishy-washy
Lando Calrissian audiences last got to
see a young girl and Oh played by the
devilishly charming Donald Glover and
solo a Star Wars story which told the
origin story of his relationship with
Han the seat taken
[Music]
nobody's in the seat Kinane taking fun
but in the rise of Skywalker the
original Lando will return
Williams is reprising his role in
episode 9 closing one of the longest
gaps between portrayals of the same
character in cinematic history even
though it's exciting to hear that one of
the original trilogy's most popular and
beloved characters will finally return
it also remains a mystery exactly why
Lando is back especially considering
that he was conspicuously absent from
this trilogies first two films what role
will he play in the story how will he
react to the news that Han died at the
hands of his own son finally will he
side with the resistance or turn sides
when it becomes convenient for him the
sudden death of Carrie Fisher in 2016
was incredibly devastating to Star Wars
fans Carrie Fisher whose role as
Princess Leia in Star Wars vaulted her
to pop culture immortality died today in
Los Angeles after all her portrayal of
an older Leia Organa who'd become a
resistance general without losing any of
her grits was an unexpected turn between
trilogies considering that many believed
episode 9 would feature Leia and an even
bigger role than the relatively
significant ones she played in 7 & 8 it
remains to be seen how she will actually
appear on screen JJ Abrams and others
have revealed that thanks to unused
footage from the first two films it's
possible for Fisher to posthumously
appear in the rise of Skywalker without
resorting to a CGI version of her
character though fans might prefer that
her last appearance end on an ambiguous
note still considering that pond died in
the force awakens and Luke died in the
last Jedi there's a decent chance that
this final film will see leia joining
her two party friends and loved ones
it's clear that the storied skywalker
name is still of the utmost importance
in the sequel trilogy reinforced by the
news that episode 9s official title is
the rise of skywalker
of course this led to plenty of
questions about what that means and how
it reflects on the plots of this final
installment kylo Ren may have told ray
that she came from quote nobody but
director JJ Abrams seems determined to
return to the mystery he set up in the
force awakens telling fans that the
identity of Rey's parents will still
prove important in episode 9 it's
possible that Rey
who possesses a stunning amount of power
for such a young untrained Jedi could
still be the titular Skywalker aside
from her kylo Ren is technically half
Skywalker on his mother's side and could
turn back to the light and reclaim his
heritage it's even possible that a new
character could take up the Skywalker
mantle and rise to fight alongside our
heroes with all that said the biggest
question still stands
who is the Skywalker in the title and
what purpose will they serve in episode
9 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stop or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]